this altitude for my books I've loved on
the Tim Ferriss Show is exclusively
brought to you by audible there couldn't
be a better sponsor for this series my
dear listeners and readers I have used
audible for so many years as long as I
can remember I love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I listen when
I'm taking walks I listen while I'm
cooking I listen whenever I can and if
you're looking for a place to start
I can recommend three of my favorites
the first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time touches on stoic philosophy
calmness under duress etc the next is
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman GA IMA
n one of my favorites even if you're a
nonfiction purist this is the fiction
book that you need to listen to neo also
has perhaps the most calming voice of
all time in 3rd Gregg McEwan's
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less this is one of my
favorite books of the past few years
combines very well with the 8020
principle but more inaudible every month
audible members get one credit for any
audiobook on the site plus a choice of
multiple audible originals from a
rotating selection they also get access
to daily news digests from the likes of
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post as well as
guided meditation programs and here are
some other amazing audible features and
I use a bunch of these you can download
titles and listen offline anytime
anywhere I use this feature even when I
could get access I'll put my phone on
say airplane mode because I want to get
bothered with notifications and I'm
taking a walk to clear my head and you
can listen to you titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever
obviously I'm not flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and
tablets you can listen across devices
without losing your spot and whisper
sync is another feature I use quite a
lot
I love reading my kindle in bed for
instance then picking up at the same
exact spot where I left off when I go
walking and listening the next day
Kindle and audio versions can be synched
up automatically it's just amazing and
if you can't decide with ELISA - don't
sweat it you don't have to rush you can
keep your credits for up to a year and
use them for instance to binge on a
whole series if you like audible offers
just about everything podcasts guided
wellness programs theatrical
performances a list comedy and audible
originals you won't find anywhere else
and right now audible is offering you
guys that's Tim Ferriss show listeners a
free audiobook with a 30 day trial
membership and again my list if you want
to check them out the Tao of Seneca the
graveyard book essentialism those are
just three there's so many good ones out
there just go to audible.com slash tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs then download your free
title and start listening it's that easy
let's check it out go to audible.com
slash Tim or text Tim TI m2 500 500 to
get started today check it out
audible.com slash tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is usually my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out that habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you
please enjoy hi this is Kevin Kelley
I'm senior maverick at Wired magazine
and I'm an author of a couple books
mostly about future technology but in a
previous life I ran a magazine called
the whole earth review and coevolution
quarterly that reviewed books on a
regular basis and in that capacity I
have read through evaluated I don't know
many many many thousands of books I'm
speaking right this moment in a
two-story library of my own that's
filled with many many thousands of books
that I own I love books I read books I
write books and so I care about the kind
of books that change people's minds and
I want to talk about a few of those kind
of books briefly I want to tell you
about four books that have changed my
mind and maybe they'll change your mind
I think the power of a book to change
people's mind is an amazing superpower
that we could hand something that little
scribbles on it and it would change how
you thought and maybe even look at the
world
because I'm gonna recommend our
non-fiction books but fiction can
certainly do that there have been books
a fiction that I've read they have
changed my view but I'm going to talk
about four non-fiction books that
changed my mind and I'm going to start
with the most recent one one that has
just come out a matter of weeks ago and
it's called open borders and open
borders is a graphic novel that's what
we call a comic book for adults and it's
a graphic novel written by an economist
Brian Caplan and the graphic novel is
illustrated by an artist
Zach Wiener Smith and together they have
made this comic book for adults which is
about the science and ethics of
immigration and it's probably one of the
most radical books that I have read in
years and it's radical because it has a
radical idea and the radical idea simply
is that everybody in the world
individually in every country in the
world would benefit from having open
borders meaning the ability or the right
for anybody to live anywhere they want
if they obey local laws now there are
going to be variations of that principle
but the basic premise is is that you
have open borders that you don't have
borders that restrict where people can
live and work and in a certain kind of
intellectual level we can imagine some
future society on this planet where it
becomes a universal human right to be
able to migrate and live anywhere you
want on the planet as long as you obey
local and that idea it seems very
strange to many people right now it
seems unworkable or idealistic or in
some ways simply a fantasy and by
capelin in this book goes through this
scientific economic reasons all
researched and evaluated and makes a
very clear fast fun case with comics
about why our kind of intuition
may be wrong about this and why the fact
is is that it is the most and best
economic thing we could possibly do for
ourselves and for others and there again
there are many objections about that you
may have many obvious ones and he goes
through all of them offering reasons why
those objections aren't true showing the
data why it's not true but at the end of
the book he even goes a little bit
further and says well even if you kind
of don't accept all my arguments and you
decide that maybe we meet some halfway
measures he offers a bunch of different
when he calls keyhole solutions that are
less than this perfect open borders but
it's still superior to what we have and
I'm maybe not giving credit because it
sounds very dull and boring but in fact
because it's a graphic novel it reads
very fast there's a kind of actually
humor element in it and it's very very
clear it's very methodical and I believe
it might even change your mind if you
have some doubts about the premise so
that's open borders very new very
current very radical very persuasive and
fun to read the second book is one
that's a little bit older and is written
by a friend of mine Stuart brand who
used to be the editor and it was the
founder of the Whole Earth Catalog and
he's read a lot of books too but he
wrote a book that I really found changed
my mind about the spaces that I live in
the structures that we work in the
buildings that surround our lives and
his books called how buildings learn by
Stewart Brand and it's an illustrated
book with lots of pictures but the main
thesis of this book is that when you
make building when you build something
when you build a structure when you
build a home or office building or even
a factory you're making a prediction
about what you think is gonna be used
for cuts because you're gonna design it
first with certain uses in mind and like
all predictions most of these buildings
will be not use
over the long term for what they were
and originally bell for people builds
homes and they have additional kids and
they need to remodel and then they begin
to remodel or they or they won a Home
Office and so commercial buildings are
constantly being renovated and for
different kinds of stores are different
from a store to a warehouse a warehouse
to store and store its idea is that we
should build buildings with the idea
that they're going to be modified so you
want to make them sort of easy or ready
to be modified by the current people who
are using him and that the building's I
serve lasts the longest or actually ones
that been modified many times and
therefore they are the ones that sort of
are more able and capable of being
modified and he calls that learning so
this is idea that when we want to make
our surroundings or offices the places
that we live in we should keep in mind
that we're probably going to modify what
they're being used for and therefore
we're going to modify those spaces and
so we want to make adaptable structures
adaptable spaces and it doesn't mean
some high-tech thing that might mean
mean making something square shell
that's very easy to modify within it
kind of depends but the point is is that
buildings are adaptable and adapted in
time so you want to think of structures
is having the element of time that
changed my mind the third book they want
to talk about the change my mind was a
book called the innovators dilemma by
clay Christensen it's kind of famous now
they may not be a hundred percent
correct in all its details because it
was based on some data that was
preliminary but the basic idea is that
when you're trying to do innovation that
there's a dilemma in the innovation
there's a dilemma in the organization
that's trying to make the innovation and
the dilemma is simply that in the
short-term it makes more sense to
incrementally improve what you know how
to do
rather than throwing it out and starting
over and taking a chance on something
new and maybe bigger that might not work
and that in a business sense it always
makes more sense at the business bottom
line in the short term to just
incrementally improve what works and
that to take a chance to do the risk of
innovation which is very likely to fail
and that's almost the definition of
innovation is that most of time is going
to fail with the chance that you may
have a hit a higher yield doesn't really
make short-term economic sense you have
to take a longer view if the calculus
only works if you're willing to take a
longer view and so the dilemma is how do
you do that how do you balance that risk
of improving excellence in what you know
how to do versus going with non
excellence going with failure in trying
something new so people think that it's
always obvious that you want to innovate
but the point of this book is that it's
actually not obvious that you actually
have to kind of go beyond the obvious
you have to kind of push through the
obvious because the obvious thing is to
not innovate and so he gives case
studies about why he believes is true
and that AHA to me really changed my
mind
about thinking about how you'd be
creative because to some people being
creative seems natural and the obvious
thing to do but if you really are
creative it's not going to always be so
obvious and that is actually when you
want to remember this book which is that
you have to take a longer-term view to
kind of continue trying to innovate
innovative Salima clay Christensen and
the last one I want to talk about is
another book to change my mind called
finite and infant games by James cars'
this is a little-known book it's kind of
hard to read it's written by kind of a
theologian
a lot of it I mean it was kind of
written in the language of religious
orientation a lot of is really maybe not
so useful but read the first and last
chapters and the basic premise that
changed my mind was to understand that
in the world there were two kinds of
games there were finite games in which
there were winners and losers we often
call that a zero-sum if somebody wins
someone else has to lose and in those
kind of games the rules are fixed
you have fairness if someone is breaking
the rules that's unfair you don't want
to play and you play until somebody wins
and most of the games in the world
they're about winning and losing but
there's another kind of game called the
infinite game and there there aren't
winners or losers the rules are not
fixed you're conic constantly changing
the rules just to extend the game and
the purpose of the game is just to keep
the game going the purpose of the game
is to bring as many people in to play
the game the purpose of the game is to
kind of invent new games and that
nonzero-sum
or what we might want to call the
positive some is really the basis of
most of the good things we have in life
in a certain sense you could say that a
company that is working or successful
isn't if in a game because if it's
really doing its job well it's not
taking from other competitors is
actually enabling other people to do
their own thing it's actually creating
jobs and creating money flow and
creating new objects and services and
goods that can be improved upon and used
by others may be making ecosystem it's
in some ways enlarging the pie rather
than just taking a slice of the pie and
that idea of kind of the ever-expanding
pie is the view that I now see the world
and in helps me kind of look at things
and even decide what to do by saying is
this a finite game and that I don't want
to play or is this an infinite game in
which sign me up so find out infinite
games james cars' the
our four books that changed my mind and
maybe they will change yours I hope they
do thanks Tim for giving me a chance to
rant about some favorite books bye hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email for me every
Friday an event provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and 500 Friday
is a very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include a
favorite articles that I have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour work week come that's
four hour work week calm all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will
get the very next one and if you sign up
I hope you enjoy
you
[Applause]